لاتخاذ هذا القرار وهو اعلى
تنبيه يمكن ان تصدر. لم يتخيل
الامريكان ان تصل الصين الى قلب
عاصمتهم بهذه الجرأة. وبينما
للقيام بعمليات ارهاب في ايران.
على غرار برقدار تركيا تكشف عن
الدفاعية التركية عن ان برنامج
المسيرات البحرية التركية يشمل
سبعين دولة فاعلنت منظمة الصحة
العالمية حالة طوارئ صحية انتشار
عملاء تابعين للموساد الاسرائيلي
دخلوا البلاد من اقليم كردستان
يصل تعدادهم الى المئات مع
الالاف من المتعاطفين معهم لا
باحتلال اراضي الفلسطينية خصوصا
قمم الجبال بحماية قوات الجيش
وزارة الاستخبارات الايرانية
تعلن تفكيك واعتقال شبكة من
الاسرائيلي ابرز شعاراتهم الموت
للعرب ينشطون بكثرة لسرقة
العالم? الارهاب لا دين له.
اعتداء وتسميم ابار المياه
الافريقية. كما سيجتمع لافروف مع
الامين العام لجامعة الدول
العربية. هي زيارة روسية تحمل
دلالات ورسائل عدة في حين يشهد
منطقة الاناضول تقول انقرة ان
الكشف يجعلها تمتلك ثاني اكبر
الازمة فهل هو فشل اوروبي فعلا?
ذروة تركية. يكفي لتزويد العالم
الف عام اكتشاف تركي يعزز انتاج
السيارات الكهربائية ويوفر
حاملا رسالة من الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لنظيره المصري
المصرية في اطار الجامعة العربية
سعيا لتسوية الازمة الاوكرانية.
بصواريخها بعيدة المدى عالية
الدقة سفينة حربية اوكرانية
السيارات الكهربائية تحتاج الى
عدة معادن منها ما يسمى بالعناصر
المسؤول الهندي بحالة تسمم والام
شديدة في المعدة. نقل على اثرها
حالية بالفاشلة وتحدث عن سقوط
اربع حكومات اوروبية منذ بداية
الغاز. بينما يسعى الاوروبيون
الى مستقبل امن للطاقة تتعرض
يستفيق من جائحة كورونا حتى ظهر
جدر القردة. تفشى الفيروس في
روسيا ادت العملية العسكرية في
اوكرانيا الى ارتفاع في جميع
وسقطة مدوية. وبعد مرور يومين
فقط من شربه هذا الكوب اصيب
باتخاذ خطوات تصعيدية دبلوماسية
ضد انقرة. وقالت الخارجية
ومنشأة لاصلاح السفن الحربية
فضلا عن مستودع لصواريخ هاربون
ومواشيهم. الاحداث والتطورات. لن
يمر القصف على محافظة داهوك مرور
تتجاوز اعمارهم في الغالب خمسة
وعشرين عاما تم السماح لهم
تحاول واشنطن مفاوضة بكين على
الاراضي الصينية جاءتهم الضربة
الكرام. هكذا اتسم الموقف
العراقي ازاء الهجمة الاخيرة
الجيش العراقي. الاتراك يحتلون
العديد من المناطق شمالي العراق.
خمس مركبات مختلفة تتمتع كل منها
بمميزات وخصائص عسكرية وتقنية
المواطنين بعد هدم بيوتهم
وخيامهم وسرقة ممتلكاتهم
العراقية انها ستتخذ الاجراءات
اللازمة. ويجب على انقرة الا
كلبين الذي تقدسه جماعة السيخ في
الهند. يا لها من ثقة مفرطة
لدى الحكومة توجه الى جارتها.
وزير الدفاع العراقي يتهم تركيا
الاراضي الفلسطينية لبناء
مستعمرات استيطانية ويطردون
الى المستشفى. انه ليس ماء زمزم
ايها الهندوس. لم يكد العالم ان
تجعل الازمة تمتد بينها وبين حزب
العمال الكردستاني الى العراق.
روسي. اتفاق الامس الذي لم ينتهي
بتصافح ها هو اليوم يلفظ انفاسه
باستغلال الحرب على داعش للدخول
في الاراضي العراقية رئيس اركان
خمسة زوارق بحرية مسيرة جديدة
ولاول مرة كشفت رئاسة الصناعات
المرض في جميع انحاء العالم
بوتيرة متسارعة دفع المنظمة
وبرغم نفي تركيا اي صلة لها
بالحادثة. الا ان اصابع الاتهام
يوجد اسلحة في وتم ضربه بشكل
تعسفي والهدف من القصف هو الغاء
مختلفة. رئيس وزراء اقليم
البنجاب الهندي يشرب ماء من نهر
في مهده ولم يكن الا جزءا من
نشاط من التجسس الصيني الذي بدأ
وتعد مصر الدولة الاولى التي
يزورها لافروف خلال جولته
العالمية. فهل هو كذلك حقا? حليف
عربي قوي. لافروف يصل القاهرة
وتسعمائة وثمانية وتسعين. هم
مجموعة استيطانية صهيونية متطرفة
واجتثاث حقول الزيتون. ممارسات
عدائية ضد فلسطيني الضفة الغربية
الطاقة بين دول القارة العجوز
معها ينشق الصف الاوروبي تجاه
كادت ان تتحول لاكبر مركز تجسس
على الولايات المتحدة في تقرير
من قبل تنظيم ارهابي يعرف بفتية
التلال الذي انطلق عام الف
الروسي مع افريقيا. فهل تفكر
روسيا في تجميع حلفائها حول
توافق مع مصر في قضايا عدة
والعقوبات الغربية تعيق التعاون
دولة عالمية في هذا المجال.
والصين ترد اللا مجال للمقارنة.
العالم تغييرات في التحالفات
وصراعات اقطاب. لافروف قال هناك
الاوروبي باتباع مقاربة جديدة مع
روسيا واصفا الخطوات الاوروبية
الثنائية بين البلدين. والاعراب
عن التقدير الروسي للمبادرة
باتفاقية القمح مع اوكرانيا.
روسيا لا تخاف وتعترف بهجماتها
الارضية التي تتكفل الصين بتزويد
العالم منها بنسبة ثمانين الى
تسعين بالمئة. وارتفعت هذه
النسبة العام الماضي الى ثمانية
التركي وقللت من اهميته. وقالت
ان الكشف لن يؤثر في مكانتها
الصين تلك العناصر وزارة التركية
اعلنت الكشف عن ستمائة واربعة
وتسعين مليون طن من الرواسب خلال
تنقيب في مدينة اسكي الشهير في
صادقا فاين الضامنون للاتفاق
اذا? بينما صرحت اوكرانيا انه لا
فيما الغرب يتهمها بعدم الايفاء
باتفاقياتها. واذا كان الغرب
مضطهدي المسلمين هناك? موسكو
تتحالف مع دولة عربية ذات قوة
عسكرية ضخمة. فكيف سيرد
الامريكان وحرب احلاف موسكو
مع موسكو. هناك قال رئيس الوزراء
الانجاري لبقية دول الاتحاد
احتياطي في العالم. صناعة
البطاريات التي تعمل بها
عام لهذه الحديقة. لكن السي اي
ايه كشفت مشروع الحديقة الذي قتل
الاخيرة موسكو اذا بقصف ميناء
اوديسا احد ثلاثة منافذ نص عليها
عبدالفتاح السيسي. وتضمنت
الرسالة التأكيد على عمق العلاقة
التي تضرب اوروبا وما تخلفه من
حرائق للغابات. تلتهب ازمة
انحاء اوروبا. وادى ارتفاع
الحرارة الشديد الى طلب كثيف على
موسكو التزامها بتصدير السلع
الغذائية بغض النظر عن رفع
وحدتهم للانشقاق. حيث طالبت هون
جاريا بتغيير استراتيجية التعاطي
العقوبات عنها او عدم رفعها
بينما تشكك واشنطن بالتزام روسيا
للمنتجين العالميين مستلزمات
صناعة البطاريات. بعد احتكار
اتفاق اسطنبول لتصدير الحبوب لكن
موسكو تؤكد انها استهدفت
حتى انه اليوم يحقق مع شركة
هواوي للامر ذاته فيا لدهاء
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
والوكالة الفيدرالية التحقيق فيه
الاتفاقية. انقسام اوروبي. في ظل
موجة درجات الحرارة اللاهيبة
الامريكية عن اي مكر روسي نتحدث
يا سادة هناك قال لافروف ان
ولجأت الصين الى هذه الحيلة
الخطيرة من خلال وضع تماثيل
تحرج الغرب بتنفيذ التزامها.
تركيا تعلن منافستها للصين كاول
نشرته شبكة سي ان ان الامريكية
قالت ان الصين قدمت عرضا للادارة
هذه المرة من داخل القارة
العجوز. ومنظمة الصحة العالمية
اصحاب العيون الضيقة جعلوا
امريكا تدور حول نفسها. مكر
المسؤولين المحليين الذين كانوا
يأملون في جذب الاف السياح كل
تطلق صفارة الانذار لمواجهة
الوباء الجديد. هل نحن مقبلون
وهياكل وابراج ترتفع سبعين قدما.
الامر الذي اثار حينها اعجاب
وتسعين بالمائة في الاتحاد
الاوروبي. الصين انتقدت الاعلان
الامريكية في الفين وسبعة عشر
بانفاق مائة مليون دولار لبناء
تتواصل ضد واشنطن? العراق يتخذ
اجراء جديدا ضد انقرة وتركيا
حديقة صينية زخرفة في الحديقة
الوطنية في العاصمة واشنطن.
حديقة بكين في واشنطن. حديقة
صينية في مشتل واشنطن الوطني
تتهرب بينما تستعرض بمسيرات
بحرية حديثة. وهكذا نفذت ايران
على جائحة عالمية جديدة؟ وهنا
فلسطين تستغيث من ارهابي جديد.
ضربة موجعة للموساد الاسرائيلي.
كوارث اوروبا لا تنتهي. والصراخ
الصين تخطط لبناء حديقة لها في
قلب واشنطن للتجسس. قنبلة فجرها
وهكذا انكشفت خرافة قدسية
الهنود. فهل هي استجابة لدعوة من
على ارضهم وبين جماهيرهم. فيا
لدهاء اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
روسيا واوكرانيا يلفظ انفاسه
الاخيرة قبل ان يجف حبره وموسكو
الامريكان فما الذي يخطط له
التنين الصيني واتفاق الامس بين